Prince Harry and his wife like the sound
of that wife Megan will not wait long to
resume their royal duties after their
historic wedding they'll be back at work
tomorrow more than 29 million TV viewers
in the US watched the couple get married
on Saturday
that's nearly six and a half million
more than Prince William and Kate
Middleton's wedding back in 2011 by the
way they got married on a Friday the
ceremony matched British royals with
Hollywood's elite including Oprah George
and Amal Clooney and James Corden
entertainment tonight's Kevin Frazier
co-hosted our live coverage of the
wedding
he's outside Buckingham Palace right now
Kevin good morning good to see you again
good to see it's not the same without
you being here again I got to tell you
that but the newly the newlyweds will
have their first official engagement as
a married couple tomorrow here at
buckingham palace it's a garden party to
celebrate the 70th birthday of Harry's
father Prince Charles and you know this
nation is still buzzing about this
couple and also the wedding which was as
much a celebration of love as it was a
celebration of change
from the very first moment Megan Marco
appeared before the world the wedding
made an early statement about pushing
the royal family into a modern era
Marco chose British designer Claire wait
Keller the first female artistic
director at French fashion house
Givenchy to create her silk white dress
she really admired the fact that or as a
woman designer and the fact that I'm a
working mother may be played into that
as well the new duchess of sussex walked
down the aisle alone before being joined
halfway by England's future King Prince
Charles as an anxious looking Prince
Harry waiting the bride's mother Doria
Raglan sat directly opposite Queen
Elizabeth in a ceremony that he mixed
tradition
with diversity you just tell the love of
Jesus how he died to save us all
oh that's the bombing giving us Bishop
Michael Curry delivered a fiery sermon
that punctured through the solemn
decorum of st. George's Chapel dr. King
was right we must discover the love the
redemptive power of love and left some
members of the royal family
both amused and bemused after the
wedding Currie told CBS News he was
speaking directly to the bride and groom
we got to get you all married no matter
how big or small the wedding may be
talked to the couple and when you talk
to the couple that you're talking to
their souls you're gonna actually
stumble on and talk to some other ones
along the way after sharing so much of
their wedding with the world the
newlyweds drove through Windsor Castle
to a private reception the bride wore an
emerald-cut aquamarine ring a gift from
Prince Harry that belonged to his mother
Princess Diana
now the couple spent last night at
Kensington Palace which will be their
permanent home and the Duchess of Sussex
already has her website up it says I'm a
proud woman and feminist and Gayle I
need you at some point today to pull out
a fascinator I think the fascinator days
are over for now Kevin but I'm curious
about what it's like because in Windsor
people still did not want to leave that
town are you finding that to be the case
no yeah people are still buzzing I think
that wedding as you know was such a
unifying moment it changed this nation
and it changed the monarchy forever
all right you weren't here Saturday
night but the bishop Currie is already
the skit on Saturday Night Live where
people are saying he changed it in a way
that people never thought possible which
i think is also very interesting thank
you well thank you guys in the entire
CBS team you guys did a terrific job it
was beautiful to watch the coverage was
really fantastic that location you have
yeah yeah yeah but you know it Nora it
really does take a village you expect it
to work when you're out there but there
are a lot of moving parts so too you
know everybody ray Ortiz Ryan character
the team it was amazing and it was a
group effort it takes a village of
course we will talk about that a little
bit later on in this broadcast with Tina
Brown great village yes